I might get a sword on my face like a
claimed war rock-and-roll so I got the
sword on my face swords are an awesome
and I've always been into them since a
little kid so I figured you know what
better make my mom have been a nice big
Claymore on my face I feel like the face
tattoos make me interesting to look at
so where I might lack and enhance them
this I make up for an intrigue at least
I think it looks dope I think I like me
whenever I look in the mirror I look at
myself and it's not even like they're
there it's weird and then whenever I get
drunk and look at it it's like well I
have all these tattoos all over my face
the stay-away is inspired by peeps
crybaby tattoo I thought it was tough
ish
I picked one of my favorite Nirvana
songs and just put it on my face I loved
playing blackjack so I was in Montreal
and I was like let's get tattooed and
then I got a blackjack on my face for
fun it's usually like a two-hour process
of me saying I want to get a tattoo and
then coming around to figuring out what
I want chugging some nice cold ones and
you know getting after it
I have an accidental marshmallow tattoo
but I was gonna do a smiley face but I
was like okay what if he has like X's
for his eyes and then I looked in the
mirror and it's in marshmallows helmet
on my face under my eyes this is always
tired
cuz I'm always tired you know always
tour and always working not taking care
of myself the way that I need to I
figured it was just very fitting for how
I felt so this was the only face tattoo
that hurt I mean these didn't really
hurt because they're so fast but this
one took a while and it was like getting
poked on your eyeball through your
eyelid that was the only one that hurt
on my face I don't know I just think
barbed wire is cool and it was a cool
idea to do it is like a trim I'm gonna
regret it when I start balding by then
hopefully I can do the whole the whole
head maybe next time we do this I'll
have my whole head tattooed I definitely
got a lot more since we spoke I don't
even remember what I had whenever I
first came to y'all I can't even keep
track anymore it's all just kind of been
a blur the Playboy bunny was my first
tattoo and I got that when recording
Stoney and me and Justin were playing
basketball and he did up it looks like
it's molten hot magma this was my first
hand tattoo it's a st.
he's like lifting up his robe and
there's like a skeleton coming out and I
just thought it looked bitchin he was on
the to young cover - the same guy does
anybody know his name any good
Christians in the house
[Music]
it's a cow skull there's really nothing
- I just think it would be cool and then
I do it but people zoom in real close
and they say it looks like an old man's
but I don't see it
it's all about perspective Kyle I have a
bunch of guys Kyle Ricky I tattooed my
friend Kyle the other day a Philadelphia
Eagles logo and it turned out pretty
good it's like my eighth tattoo that
I've done and they've never been on that
scale but it turned out really really
good I think I tattooed my friend Bobby
a bunch of times I gave him a pizza I
just like tattooing my friends if they
let me and this newest work was my best
work ever
I got Kurt Peep Bob and just a bunch of
other cool rock and roll type stuff I
have this nice Texas flag skull type
deal I got the Motorhead logo here this
is like a cool little Centurion type
elbow this is a cool ass demon samurai
skull from gonji from Japan and this is
also from gonji but this is a guy
getting his face ripped off this is a
minute man this is Sauron from Lord of
the Rings he's the coolest character
have you seen him she's huge and he has
a cool ass mace what else do you want
from the villain I guess but this one
has to be finished a lot of these - I
have to finish because I can't sit
I'm weakling and it hurts real bad so I
just tap out and say will do later but I
don't want to this is pretty cool it's
like a guy on a horse stabbing a guy
with the spear this is me on a horse I
think we got a picture from up from a
game my friend Kyle he just put my face
on it and my friend Ricky hooked me up
and and did it I got to add the face
tattoos to my tattoo and so it's like
tattoo inception and if I get a tattoo
of my face on my face then it could go
on forever
tiny tiny tiny oh this bicep this one
this is patient because we were shooting
a music video for my son patient it
never came out but we wanted to get
tattooed in the video so we got this
tattoo that hurt like a mother
surprisingly I don't know why this is
Gallants ins logo this is praying hands
with you can't see it make sure to Atari
he's holding a Glock here I have a big
zombie Easter Jesus Jesus is very
handsome so I figured how could we make
him super metal and so he made him
Easter Jesus these are just drunk
knights and we're just like get let's
get after it my stomach I have a big
come and take it
Spartan stuff and Master Shake from Aqua
Teen Hunger Force that tattoo actually
hurt a lot and it's dumb because it's a
milkshake and it hurt the most it's
interesting to you know look back at the
photos of whenever I had no tattoos and
it's just bizarre to see like it becomes
such a part of you that you don't even
notice but whenever you notice you're
like damn I don't think I have any
regrets tattoo eyes it's all a time in a
moment if you want to get something
don't let your friend stop you you know
don't be too drunk in making the
decision I suppose that's what it would
be advice for the first base tattoo is
yeah get after it